when you talk about replicating this
team I don't I don't know if it's
possible if I could start from scratch
and said I want to I want to duplicate
the Warriors I don't think I could do it
the Warriors had plans and ideas and the
initial ones almost none of them came
through to make this team it took some
luck probably sounds a lot easier than
it that it is stars was really not
behind there's a blueprint for a
championship team here but I'm not sure
that it's one that any other team could
then try to replicate it has to be
remembered there wasn't a whole lot of
pride in this Warriors organization no
single event Illustrated how far the
Warriors had fallen as the night that
they came together to retire Chris
Mullins Jersey they just traded another
one of their favorites Monta Ellis these
are the fans who had seen player after
player who had passed through gone on to
greatness elsewhere and a lot of people
thought that this was just an attention
grab and so they let Joe Lake of have it
and if they looked a little more closely
and maybe studied Chris Mullins reaction
that night they would have seen this is
the beginning of something everything
work out just fine just a little bit of
patience use that passion
[Applause]
most elite NBA teams you can kind of see
them coming from a distance because they
just grab that big flashy star
free-agent or they just got the number
one overall pick
the Warriors never did any of that if
the Warriors are a championship team of
what ifs
then Steph Curry their MVP is the
biggest what-if of all there's nobody in
the NBA like them there's nobody in the
world like it for me to get a chance
firsthand to see him coming out of
college people knew this guy is a great
shooter but they weren't sure what his
NBA position was is he really a
playmaker is he too skinny all of these
questions hovered over him Ricky Rubio
[Applause]
Johnny Flynn from Syracuse University
step and courage still available the
Golden State Warriors select Stefan
Curry from Davidson
it's not like the Warriors of that
moment stopped everything had a big
party we got a future MVP physically
could he hold up ankle injuries the
riders career heartbreaking is all I can
say as a result of him not being on the
floor a whole lot they were able to get
yet another lottery pick a lot of the
buzz that night was about Jimmer mania
maybe the most talked-about player in
this trap when I saw Jimmer go front of
me I was happy for I started oh but I'm
a little nervous cuz you know you don't
know we're gonna be slotted at the star
has a line I was the very next pick klay
Thompson from Washington State
University San Chandler but he turned
them down to join the New York Knicks
they then put an offer sheet out for
restricted free agent DeAndre Jordan
that didn't work Andrew Bogut at that
time to a lot of people was looked at as
just another bust the Warriors traded
Monta Ellis a fan favorite for an Andrew
Bogut who wasn't even playing at the
time he was injured this is the first
guy they brought in who really thought
defense first Harrison Barnes was
expected to be a shrewd choice but there
wasn't a whole lot of excitement the
feeling was that Harrison had actually
been better as a freshman and so that
was a nice pickup but nobody saw the
second-round pick becoming the player
that he has become draymond Green
terrific player in the second round
shocking that he would get there to it
but these drafts sometimes go unexpected
a second-round pick 35th overall so by
definition you're not expecting stardom
emotionally the driving force of this
team and the conscience of this team as
far as how it needs to play to be able
to come and blend in with these guys and
you know try to do what I can do to help
this team out
you could tell it was a brotherhood
brewing from the start and it's been
something special that's happened over
the course of these last four years for
me 2013 saw a lot of things break their
way as well
to sit across from an elite player who
had many options to hear him say you
guys are building something that I want
to be a part of that moment for us as an
organization was a big one there were a
lot of question marks around andre
iguodala a starter for his entire career
had never come off the bench exactly how
would he fit in they're still looking
for upgrades and Dwight Howard had
several options certainly considered the
Warriors but he ends up choosing the
Houston Rockets so the Warriors stand
pat and might have even dodged a bullet
the summer of 2014 was almost as poor to
attest as the summer of 2013 let's start
with the fact that they nearly upset the
Clippers ultimately if they win the game
7 and go to the second round
it would have been awfully hard to fire
Mark Jackson at that point the fact of
the matter is Steve Kerr was not number
one on their list Stan Van Gundy was the
toughest thing about taking the Warriors
job was turning Phil Jackson down I had
told him if we can work out a contract
I'm coming to New York that was right
when the Warriors came in and
interviewed me there was so much talent
on the Golden State roster and not as
much on the Knicks roster frankly but I
knew immediately that's where I wanted
to be I just thought it was a perfect
fit for the personnel that the Warriors
already had one
the things you wanted to make sure was
that we had the trust of our players I
can tell you how to bring my for the
game such a great shooter his career you
can teach me little nuances about
shooting it can really expand my game
and I just knew get a vision by the
summer of 2014 the Warriors know they
have something special with Steph Curry
and klay Thompson but they're missing
some element in the frontcourt and so
they're looking at Kevin Love who's
looking to get out of Minnesota the
trade of klay Thompson for Kevin Love
made a lot of sense so there was a
heated debate among Warriors officials
about whether to make that deal but in
the end the keep klay Thompson forces
one out was in love with NBA growing up
the business side was new to me it came
out like you had something to prove
[Applause]
I'd be wondering what the NBA record is
for most points in a quarter you just
watched it I just saw the potential how
well guys were fitting together
that was a huge game-changer as far as
how this team operated it was a long
path every single year I was with the
new team there wasn't anybody who would
have ever said you know this is a guy
who one day is gonna be the key member
of a championship bench coming in we all
didn't know exactly what to expect you
could tell that we were trending in the
right direction and we starting to put
it together and figure some things out
as that first season was going
on you could see that trust building
there was a moment when I looked around
I said you noticed our team is going to
be amazing if curry had been a star on
day one if there's never any ankle
injuries the Warriors don't have the
opportunity to get klay Thompson and
Harrison Barnes in the first place and
maybe several others and I'm not
satisfied just winning one this team
definitely has a lot of room for growth
good luck trying to do something similar